i think that you need to give a woman
the opportunity to really get to know
you as a human and as a person before
you
have that conversation and the reason is
is a lot of women will stop seeing a man
they could have loved that could have
went right because of this subject yeah
but look at your relationship right and
i'm in this with complete respect
there's a gap between you and him
you you were talking about it earlier
you know that he's seeing other women
that's creating that's creating distance
between you
when you could just talk about it one
time i didn't say i know that he is i
don't know you said that you have
problems
yeah there's there's a high chance right
there's a really high chance but
i
i
i
it just hurts too much to even like
bring that up then write him a note do
something because i'm telling you what
you're costing yourself
is if he feels guilt about it and i
promise you he does especially in the
western world
then what's happening is he's only
loving you to a certain degree
and he's protecting himself because he's
worried that if he gets caught you're
going to leave but if you could just
snap that and let him know that you
already know because you clearly already
know
if you could just let him have that you
would be shocked at how much more
capacity to love you he would have
because he would be able to trust that
he can love you fully yeah can i get
that but it's just you know you get it
but it doesn't feel good you're scared
of it yeah it doesn't do
it doesn't feel good and you have given
me something to think about for sure but
for my situation like we're talking
about parents like my dad was so much
like paul's dad um my dad actually looks
like you did
my dad
my dad isn't a hero
but you know my parents my my parents
are no longer here like i'm not i'm not
a girl with a big business i don't earn
a lot of money like
this like my situation is different
where like he provides everything for me
i'm lucky i don't want to
invite any kind of
just yeah it doesn't feel good and if
you
had if you had to bet money
on whether he's cheating or not cheating
what would you put your money on and i
have a follow-up question about that
life or death i think this is a bit much
no i don't think it no no i think it's
completely fair if you think dude i
don't think you have to answer it
like i have a feeling because
i'm aware because i'm just aware that
the type of guy he is he's not he gets
attention from women everywhere we go
but he's a very very private person i
think that's what like helps the
situation because he's good it makes you
feel better because you think he's
private and you don't have to talk about
it
but if you had to bet you said three
times you think he is right
but why don't why do i have to bring
that up
because it's bothering you
it's bothering you and again i think
that if you guys took this
situation that's it's a wedge it's a
wedge because you know what's happening
right and i'm not trying to be ugly in
fact if anything i'm trying to be
hopeful to you no i can hear that like
i'm not i'm not trying to i'm not trying
to make a point i'm simply telling you
i've experienced this i've been with a
girl that didn't know
okay and i felt like i couldn't tell her
and because i felt like i couldn't tell
her
i would hold back like a piece of my
heart
because i was terrified that if i gave
her the whole thing and she caught me
then it would wreck me
and i'm telling you that's a that's a
wedge
and that you could stop did she ever
bring up with you did you have a child i
ended up sitting her down and telling
her
and she didn't leave
are you still with her are you still
with her wouldn't you like to know
so no
sterling sterling do i no no no way you
know what to help you hold on hold on to
help you
yes i am and sterling knows her well
i've been with her for a while yes she's
madly in love with him yeah okay for a
long time she's the most amazing woman
but the thing is is that like it is i
understand that but she won't want to
talk about that stuff with you like i'm
not i i even if yes she does like we
joke about it all the time like it's so
because but here's the thing that but
here but hear me out here i know i'm i'm
genuinely trying to help you like you're
obviously a sweetheart we've been
talking to instagram for what six months
about going on your show like what
bothers me about this for you is like
when you're you're scared
is what you're what's happening you're
scared but just like jumping out of an
airplane or doing a big business deal
the more times you touch it the less
thing it is going to have to you yeah
but i don't want to sit there i know you
i know you don't want to but
unfortunately it's a rock in your shoe
which is a rock in the relationship and
it's stopping you and him
from going to this place where you don't
talk about something that's super
uncomfortable to getting to like here
but is it though because i just i just
feel i don't want like you're sitting
there saying you you sit there with your
with your partner and you talk about
these things and you laugh about it i
wouldn't be laughing about it okay no no
i i don't think you will and neither
were we in fact there there was a time
where
every time i've told a girl this they
leave for like a week
and what they really do is go
compartmentalize it and really unpack it
and really try to make their mind up and
what what i'm telling you is
is if you and him were able to have that
understanding and not speak of it
anymore and you released that guilt or
that burden and that fear of losing you
from him you would get closer
and i think you would be likely to never
lose him because of it because very few
women can see the world for how it
actually is do you like it no do you
want a man that's going to cheat on you
no will you accept it you're already
accepting it so why not take the
benefit of getting the information
that's gonna make your love deeper
because what you're really not accepting
is him as a man because men are this way
and i don't say that to make a point i
say it because it's true he wants to
love you more
he can't because he's scared of what
he's going to lose if you see who he
really is and he can't bring the truth
to you i'm trying to do that
tell them
i i just feel that everything is is fine
with us
how it is like
it's amazing you're scared
you're scared it's not amazing because
you're scared he's cheating on you or
you don't like that feeling in your gut
because you don't want to give him full
permission because maybe somewhere he's
not he is you already know you've said
it four or five times maybe i don't know
so why don't you watch your position in
by having the conversation with him and
let him know that you love him so much
you're not gonna leave okay
for example if i had that conversation
with him he might put a ring on your
finger and he no but and he wasn't there
and he wasn't doing that that's
basically giving him a card to go yeah
i'm just gonna he's gonna do it anyway
the difference is is he gonna love you
at 110 percent or is he going to love
you at 75. i'm not sure it is absolutely
not true absolutely back to your world
view though yeah like that's like the
red world's just your opinion because it
doesn't mean anything like you think of
their relationship yeah
sterling
was the biggest manipulation i think i'd
seen in my face in a very long time
where were your feelings there was no
time it was all if you tell him and it
was the subtlety in your voice and i was
like wow this guy's good but it's the
baritones in your voice
if you tell him
that you understand
he'll open his heart up to you yeah it's
true and i was literally watching your
eyes and i was i was like it's not true
it is true because where's your feelings
in this if you're already feeling that
gut
that gut-wrenching that that's actually
really powerful and it's actually very
bad for your body that is sitting in
there that's one thing that he's saying
that is actually accurate to have the
conversation
but it's not for him to then be like oh
my god she's the one she's understanding
it's actually to is is to create a bond
with you that i'm feeling something like
we're not all together there and is
there another woman involved in this and
then you take the power it's not to say
i'm okay
if you have others because you're a
high-value man and i've adjusted that
justin's point will be that um
he explained his point just literally
it's just what about her feelings every
every every guy ultimately is gonna
behave in this manner
and here's the thing like my one
criticism of red pill is like
is that you guys will always say like
it's facts like we should believe the
facts fidelity as old as marriage
what infidelity is as old as marriage
yeah it is a hundred percent like
predominantly men no i agree with you
i'm not disagreeing but i'm saying like
if if surveys are telling you that 25 of
men cheat right and let's let's up it
and say it's 50 let's say half of them
like another i think is i think it's
less than 25 you think it's less than 20
okay yeah because i think 85 want to
and only about 10 can yeah well and if
you if you if you take well if if let's
go to the income category you take men
that make over 250 thousand dollars a
year like it ups to 50 from 25 to 50
percent of those men i think fitness
will allow you cheat more than money
all right super ripped
it's just it seems like like the red
pill guys it's just
no matter what they're cheating they're
cheating all the time but to be fair to
be friends regardless of any like data
that's put in front of them but but she
has identified her man as being a very
high value guy who who would have the
ability so he's already in that category
isn't it exactly it i know that he has
the ability he's already in that
category of the guy who would
completely be absolutely i know how many
like when we go out how many women are
like looking at him it's like it's not
the guy's looking at me it's the women
and i i sit there and i watch that
that's what makes me know yes he has got
the ability to cheat and yes i will
admit yeah in a way it does make him
more attractive but it doesn't i don't
think
i totally hear what you're saying and i
understand how you're trying to help me
but i just
don't think that sitting there having a
conversation going here's your your
green card from me i think he'd actually
like might even lose respect for me i i
i think that is a high possibility i
would respect you more because you
understand how the world actually works
i really like you may have that view but
i think that you you know your man
exactly and you know what that feeling
is and it probably does need to be a
conversation but to give him that kind
of pass and he's going to fall more in
love with you and unlock this chamber of
his heart that he has fastened away and
it's all going to open up and
no you know what you know i think i just
don't think that's reality i i think the
reason that they could convert
them out of time
you want to deal with it that's that's
my thing you don't have to sit down and
have that conversation if this is what
you choose you don't have to sit down
and have that conversation that is your
choice can i
i think justin's absolutely bang on with
with with most of what he's saying but
there is one small point that concerns
me adjusted and that is that if you get
a girl who feels like she's too much of
a pushover basically i i've lost
attraction for women not because they've
sat me down and had a conversation said
i don't care if you cheat but i've lost
sort of desire for women if i felt that
they were too there for me do you know
what i mean if they don't hold anything
back you know you think she's there i've
got her on to the next one